so ist das bauwerk ist zu mir gekommen
herr klinge bayern hat gerade gesagt das
sei ein klarer regierungsauftrag für die
spd weil die union ja so viele
prozentpunkte verliert das ist ein
argument was man immer wieder hört was
jetzt diese dem entgegen der abend ist
noch ganz jung wir werden einen langen
wahlabend erleben und es ist so wir
wissen nicht wer am ende die nase vorn
haben wird wir haben jetzt auch eine
aufholjagd erlebt der union gerade in
den letzten tagen und den letzten beiden
wochen und am ende wird es um die frage
gehen wer kann ein gutes bündnis für
deutschland schmieden darum wird es
gehen klar die verluste sind schmerzhaft
für uns aber für uns geht erst das land
dann die partei es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten nach den umfragen nach den
prognosen jetzt einmal ein schritt
zurück in die vergangenheit rot grün
wieder diesmal mit stimmen der fdp oder
ein starkes zukunftsbündnis für
sicherheit stabilität aber eben auch
klimaschutz und innovationen zwischen
union grünen und fdp es kommen ja noch
die auswahl der briefwähler da ist die
union eigentlich immer traditionell ganz
stark wie wichtig wäre es denn für
laschet und die cdu/csu dass sie vorne
liegt jede stimme zählt und deswegen
haben wir auch um jede stimme gekämpft
aber das wollen wir jetzt abwarten es
ist noch sehr früh am abend
kopf-an-kopf-rennen jetzt niemand kann
sicher voraussagen wie der abend endet
aber eher ziemlich normal wenn die wir
für union war jede stimme also wenn sie
mich fragen finden sie es gut wenn die
briefwähler ja natürlich natürlich hoffe
ich auf jeden scherz ist die chance aber
wenn die union auf platz zwei landet
dann wird doch das argument kommt man
hat ohnehin so viele prozente von 32,9
verloren dann ist man nur zweiter dann
hat man den regierungsauftrag nicht naja
also sie sehen jetzt kopf an kopf rennen
deswegen kann niemand von einem klaren
regierungsauftrag sprechen das ist klar
die spd reklamiert das würde ich an
deren stelle tun weil sonst ist es eben
nicht so eindeutig ist doch logisch es
geht am ende um die frage wer kann eine
gute zukunft koalition für dieses land
bilden und darüber muss man sprechen und
darüber muss man verhandeln und wir sind
dazu bereit abschließend zwar eine
richtige achterbahn man könnte ja sagen
von vor ein paar tagen 19 prozent ist
das jetzt ein erfolg dass man wieder
nach oben gekommen ist aber sie als
generalsekretär als wahlkampfmanager
sind sie nicht durchaus enttäuscht 25
prozent hatten sie mit nicht mit mir
rechnen müssen also unser ziel war ein
anderes ist doch ist doch klar
und ich bin es ist bitter und es tut
auch weh wenn man die verluste sieht im
vergleich zur letzten bundestagswahl wo
wir viel stärker waren und das müssen
wir auch aufarbeiten und ich finde das
darf man auch nicht schönreden
da gibt es an diesen verlusten gibt es
nichts schön zu reden aber das andere
ist diesem land zu dienen und die frage
ist kriegt man eine zukunfts koalition
hin oder nicht und darüber werden wir
sprechen vielen dank dass sie mir klar
dass meine damen und herren der
generalsekretär der cdu bei den
momentanen ergebnisprognose kann man ja
auch noch nichts sagen festzustellen
bleibt jedenfalls dass die cdu/csu
natürlich nicht das ergebnis von vor
vier jahren erreichen wird das war hier
jedem klar die frage ist hat man die
nase vorne oder nicht kann man einfluss
nehmen auf ein jamaika-bündnis bin dann
zu einem jamaika-bündnis zu gründen oder
nicht das ist die entscheidende frage
ist aus sicht des konrad-adenauer-hauses
wenn sich die zahlen des zdf verfestigen
sollte man liegt 2 3 4 prozentpunkte der
spd dann wird das hier ein ganz anderer
abend werden als wenn die cdu csu nach
wie vor die chance hat den
regierungschef zu stellen und damit
zurück zur michaela kolster